hi everyone happy wednesday
um some reminders for the course so
homework one is due tonight maybe there
are a little bit fewer people today
because maybe people are working on it
right now um maybe we should have made
it due before the lecture
um ice homework two isn't quite out yet
but it will be out tonight
um
[Music]
also
we would love for you to fill out the
project survey by today as well
um again this is non-binding we're
mostly using it to assign mentors and
it's helpful if you submit it if you
don't submit it by today then boy will
give you a mentor
after you submit your proposal
also tomorrow we have a tutorial on
variational inference this will be super
useful if you want to understand parts
of the lecture on monday
it's not required if you also the
lecture on monday
i think it's pretty useful for getting
some intuition behind
the ideas in multi-test learning and
meta-learning and
like what task structure really means
um
but if you don't if you aren't
interested in kind of diving deeper into
that then um it's also fine to
to skip that um the tutorial will be
recorded and made available on canvas
yeah
it'll be on zoom yeah uh
yeah if people have strong preferences
for in-person things we can try to do
that for the lost tutorial but there's
like a huge room shortage on campus and
so the registrar hasn't been giving us
rooms and we asked for them
cool um so
the question for today uh is
how should we define tasks uh if we want
good meta-learning performance
and we'll be looking at two different
aspects of this problem we'll briefly
recap metal learning approaches and task
construction this will give you a chance
to also ask any questions that you have
from the content from the past three
lectures
then we'll talk about the memorization
problem in med learning potential
solutions for it
and
scenarios where we can do meta-learning
without any tasks being provided
one disclaimer is that a lot of the
topics that we'll cover today are
really at the edge of research and so
i encourage you to ask questions
uh but also sometimes the answer to
those questions will be that it's an
open question that the field hasn't
figured out yet
uh the goals by the end of the lecture
are to understand what this memorization
problem is when how it occurs this is
super important if you're going to do a
project on metal learning because you
might inadvertently set things up in a
way that
causes this problem
it'll also help you understand
techniques for constructing tasks
automatically
great um so to recap we talked about
three different metal learning
approaches one is a black box approach
that parameterizes this learner as a
neural network this is very expressive
but it also leads to a challenging
optimization problem
we also saw optimization based
approaches where you embed an
optimization into the
learning process and you optimize for
this
optimizer to do well with small amounts
of data this builds in the structure of
the optimization into the meta learning
process
which is quite helpful it also requires
a second order optimization
in the lecture on monday this week we
also covered non-parametric metal
learning and the way that this works is
we compute an embedding of the examples
um the examples in the training data and
the examples for our query example
and then we essentially do some form of
nearest neighbors in order to and then
adopt product with the labels in order
to make a prediction
so the really the key idea here is to
have some sort of non-parametric learner
you want to
do this in the context of some sort of
parametric embedding function or
distance function
and so this could be k-nearer savers to
examples or k-nearest neighbors to
prototypes
this is um pretty easy to optimize it's
also computationally pretty fast because
you can get a just get the answer
through a forward pass through this
computation graph
it's also largely restricted to
classification and so if you have
problems with continuous labels
this isn't as applicable
we've also talked about constructing
task distributions and one of the kind
of canonical examples that we've looked
at throughout is
using labeled images from previous
classes in order to construct these
image classification problems
where each task corresponded to a
different n way k shot classification
problem
uh and we also looked at a couple
examples briefly of other ways that we
could form tasks for example we could
have tasks correspond to different
regions of the world where you want to
quickly adapt to a new region
or tasks could correspond to different
objects and you want to be able to
generalize new objects from say a single
demonstration
great any questions on
on this kind of review content
okay
great so
now let's talk about um
talk about memorization and before we
get into that i
am going to give you a thought exercise
and this won't actually relate to task
construction
quite yet
and in particular say you have a black
box metal learner that takes as input
the support set or the training set for
task i
then uses that to
make predictions for new examples
and
now let's say that you also have a task
identifier like a one hot id for each of
the tasks
what if you also pass this identifier
into the network in addition to passing
in
the data
does anyone have thoughts on what would
happen
during meta training time if you did
this
yeah so essentially what it can do is
now it can just learn a mapping from the
task identifier to
um to the the and the test image to the
label and ignore the training data
and in particular if the network finds
it difficult to learn from the data it
can just ignore it and purely rely on zi
yeah and for the homework that was so
similar if you didn't shuffle it right
because then it would just memorize
the images
yeah you're like two steps ahead we'll
get to there in a couple slides
um now
what happens if you pass in um
what happens at meta test time now
you now have a one hot identifier for a
new task
what will happen
yeah
yeah so it'll perform really terribly
because the one hot identifier is a new
one hot it's like a new integer that
it's never seen before and it won't
really generalize at all to the new task
because it doesn't know what it's
supposed to be doing
oh cool so this is a problem um
now second thought exercise i now
instead of having a one hot vector we
have like a natural language description
in the form of a paragraph that
describes what the network is supposed
to do
um does anyone have thoughts what will
happen in this case
will it be the same as the previous
scenario will be different
yeah so you're saying that it might
still kind of depend purely on the
description um it may not be quite as
bad as before yeah and it would depend
if all the
if that description may have an open eye
like they're very similar by the same
fortune then it would be different but
in the other case
yeah so it's a great point if the if the
paragraphs are like completely unique
then it's essentially just a unique
identifier for the tasks and you might
have something similar come up
yeah
yeah so this you may actually do better
at meta test time for the new task
because you're not just given a new one
hot integer you're at least given a
description and if it can actually
generalize from that description then it
should actually be able to solve the
task
cool
so um in particular
the a paragraph description may be more
complex to kind of infer the task from
if if they're completely unique from one
another it's going to be pretty simple
but if there's only like one character
that's different in that paragraph
it might be
difficult for it to interpret that
description and so
what the network ends up using will
probably depend on which is simpler like
if it's simpler to learn from the data
than to interpret the paragraph text it
will probably use the data if it's
simpler to use the paragraph description
then it will probably use that
description
and this also will kind of
the results by the test time will also
depend on this
and if it can actually
instead it does actually start to
interpret the text that it will actually
generalize to the test task
so you're asking like is the problem
here that essentially the network isn't
um
yeah exactly so um there are different
ways to solve the task and it could
potentially kind of take the easy way
out by just like looking at and identify
or looking at something that
differentiates in the descriptions
and kind of the crux of it is that
they're
it can essentially
kind of minimize the mediterranean loss
it can do well at all the training tasks
without looking at the training data at
all in both of these scenarios and that
means that at test time if you want it
to actually improve using the data
um it will like it won't actually be
able to do that because it learned to
completely ignore the data during meta
training
cool um so
this is a pretty important concept in
metal learning uh and the reason is that
now when you go about constructing tasks
um you need to keep in mind whether or
not you can actually interpret
whether whether it will actually learn
from the data or whether it will use
some other signal to determine what the
task is
and so in particular
one of the things that you saw in the
homework is that
we for example had kind of set up these
tasks where we had different tasks
corresponding to
different
different sets of images and we assigned
a label to each of the tasks
and we explicitly randomized the
assignment of labels to images and so um
if you look at these in like task one
the bird class is assigned a label of
zero versus in task three the bird class
is assigned a label of one
and this means that you can't actually
solve the task without looking at the
training data for each task
and
because we're randomly assigning class
labels to
image classes this means that tasks are
what i would call mutually exclusive in
the sense that you can't solve
all of the tasks with a single model
and so as a result they have to use the
data in order to infer the label
ordering and they have to use the data
to learn the problem or to learn the
task
um
cool so now what if the label assignment
is consistent across tasks
and what i mean by that is what if you
always assign the bird class a label of
zero you always assign the dog class a
label of two
the landscape a label of one and so
forth
um do people have thoughts on what will
happen here
yeah so you don't even you don't have to
look at the data at all and you don't
even actually have to look at any sort
of index either
you can essentially classify
the examples in each of these blue boxes
without with completely ignoring the
data essentially
and so the tests are what i would call
non-mutually exclusive a single function
can solve all of the tasks and solve
learn a classifier that classifies all
the examples and the blue boxes without
looking at the green boxes
and essentially the network can simply
learn to classify inputs irrespective of
the training set
yeah
so
in this case
what
the
yeah great question so it's not actually
going to be looking at anything in the
green boxes it's going to be looking at
the images in the blue box the image
that's provided at meta test time and
then it's going to predict the label
from that um it doesn't need any task
identifier because they can just look at
the image and predict the label because
the the labels are all consistent across
all the tasks
yeah it was become a vanilla
classification problem
yeah so it's important that the labels
are consistent across all the tasks also
across the the support and query sets
yeah
um with the same like the same thing if
i always take like zero and one
so we don't have consistency across
yeah so if you don't shuffle um the
order of images that you pass into the
network in the test sets in the query
sets
if you don't shuffle those then it will
always just memorize the first thing
that you give it is a label of zero the
second thing you give is label one and
so forth and in that scenario you also
don't have to look at the training data
um so if you shuffle the training data
and keep the query set in order you
still have that same problem because it
can still remember that the first query
image is a zero the second query image
is a one and so forth
um
so if if if your test examples if your
query set um always like passes in order
where the first example zero second
example is one and so forth and you have
a recurrent network then it can just
essentially learn how to count and in
that case it actually doesn't even have
to look at the images in the query set
not only does it not have to look at the
data it can just not look at the images
at all and just learn how to count and
say like this image is zero this image
is a one and so forth
um whereas
in some in some approaches if you don't
have a recurrent network and it's just a
feed-forward model then
whether or not you shuffle the the query
set is is less important
yeah
why don't we just redefine them
yeah so yeah if you randomize
if you randomize the ordering that you
pass in the images and you also
randomize the labels um you'll of course
want to make the labels consistent
between support and query but if you
randomize everything else then you won't
run into this issue
and so
in particular if you don't if you have
this consistent ordering across all the
tasks and it could ignore the training
data set this is true for a black box
approach where it will just learn this
classifier
um this is actually also true for
optimization based approaches as well
where it can
essentially learn a network
for which the gradient update doesn't
really actually affect anything and it
will still memorize and still learn a
classifier that
that ignores the the training data
cool um and so
the only thing that's a problem is if
the label ordering is consistent and it
learns to ignore the training data then
if you give it
examples of new training classes
and a support set of those training
classes
then it's not going to know what the
correct
label is for
these images
and it won't be able to solve this test
test because it because it's ignoring
the data
um and so if you actually evaluate um
mammal
with this metatrader meta test setup
you get a kind of a performance of
around seven percent for 20 way one shot
and around fifty percent for twenty way
five shot and this is a lot worse than
if you um if you actually shuffle
the the meaning of the labels across the
tasks
yeah there's one quick check so instead
of the lineup would be a dog
it would classify the dog in the two
instead of
one plate yeah exactly so if the lion
was a dog instead of a lion then it
would output a two um and that would be
the correct thing this is a problem when
you have new classes
cool now you might wonder is this
actually a problem um
in image classification we could just
shuffle the labels we know how to solve
this um
maybe all is still okay
and it's also not a problem if you see
the same image classes as you saw during
training so if we only saw like dogs and
stuff like that then it's just a
classification problem and all is also
fine
but it does become a problem
if you want to be able to adapt with
data for new tasks and you're not in
image classification settings where
where somehow the task identifier is
easy to interpret from something in the
data that you're passing in
and so as another example
say you wanted a robot to
be able to learn different tasks
and
you also want to give it a natural
language description of the problem like
closing the drawer
picking up the hammer stacking the
blocks
and we want to give it those
instructions so that it can
it can actually quickly do those tasks
and get a sense for what the task what
you're actually asking it to do
but then if you give it a test task
where you want it to learn how to close
a box it hasn't seen the closed box
instruction before but you are allowing
it to learn from data
if you try to do meta training on these
tasks and then have it learn this new
task
the robot is going to ignore the trials
that you give it the the training data
that you give it for each task
and not only will it not be able to
generalize to this task but it also
won't be able to quickly learn it
because during metatrading it just
ignored all of the training data
um as another example say we want to
predict the pose of objects or sorry the
orientation of objects
and we
have different objects in our meta
training data set
with all with a kind of a consistent
canonical orientation of each particular
object
then if you give it a new object
which has a new canonical orientation
um
in this scenario it can essentially
memorize the canonical orientation of
all the training objects and it won't
generalize to the new object from data
because it learned to
memorize the canonical orientation
rather than actually inferring the
orientation from data
cool so this is another scenario where
the model wouldn't actually be able to
learn how to predict the orientation of
a new object
okay um so
now that we've gone over the problem of
memorization uh is there something that
we can do about it
yep
yeah so essentially when it sees a couch
um it will know
if the couch was in its training data it
will know it can kind of essentially
memorize
um
like i guess to predict the orientation
of an object you need some reference
point which is what i'm referring to as
the canonical orientation
and it when it sees a couch it will know
that the canonical orientation is like
maybe facing the camera or something and
then i can just directly predict the the
orientation relative to what it the
canonical orientation it memorized
um and i can do that for all of the
objects it might be able to guess what
the canonical orientation is for a new
object if it's something that is kind of
sensible but in many cases there isn't
like
um
there isn't any sort of like universal
canonical orientation for objects
um
that is uh
that necessarily that you can like infer
from the object shape
and as a result
it's memorizing this canonical
orientation in a way that allows it to
just ignore the support set for each of
the tasks and then when it's given a new
support set it won't actually be able to
learn from that support site
yeah um so the
the labels will essentially
um tell you
so from the image um
you need to predict the the orientation
relative to the canonical orientation
the labels will tell you
um
essentially from multiple labels of an
object you can infer what the canonical
orientation is
through the the training process
okay um so can we actually do something
about this problem um
there is actually uh
there's i'll present one solution that
we can solve we can do for it i don't
think that there's really any like
amazing solution for it but i'll present
one thing that seems to work somewhat
well um and yeah if anyone has any other
ideas we can also discuss that
so
if the tests are mutually exclusive then
a single function can all solve all the
tasks or it cannot solve all the tasks
and this could be due to label shuffling
or hiding information
if they're non-mutually exclusive this
is where we run into problems because a
single function can solve all of the
tasks
and in these cases there's actually
multiple solutions to the meta-learning
problem
and in particular
one solution
for example in the case of the post
prediction example is to memorize the
canonical pose of all the training
objects in your meta parameters and
ignore the training data
and another solution is to not carry any
information about the canonical pose and
infer that from the training data
for each of the tasks
um and in reality there's actually an
entire spectrum of solutions that kind
of interpolates between these two things
that can
rely more or less on
memorization of information versus
inferring that information from the
training data
and this also suggests a potential
solution to the problem which is
there are these different
there's essentially kind of different
information that you can use to solve
each of the meta training tasks
and what you can try to do is
essentially try to control the
information flow you can
try to encourage it to
use information from one from theta or
you could try to encourage it to use
information from
the training data
does this make sense any questions
okay so um if you want to
control information flow um say we want
we want the the solution in turquoise we
want it to only acquire the information
from the training data and not actually
store the data in data
then what we could try to do um
is to
maximize the the mutual information or
the
kind of the information overlap between
the predicted labels and the training
data to encourage it to use information
from the data
unfortunately this objective is uh
is intractable to optimize we can't
directly measure mutual information very
easily
but what we're going to do instead
is we can try to minimize the
metatrading loss and also minimize the
amount of information and theta
and what this will do is because that
you can either store this information in
theta or
extract it from the training data then
minimizing the information and theta
will encourage it to use data
encourage it to use information from the
training data and encourage it to use
the training data
and
this is because you're also minimizing
the meta training loss
yeah
there would be like a prior
fire or something
yeah so the way that we're going to do
this um is we'll first minimize the
metatrading loss and then
minimizing information theta is a
difficult objective to optimize but
we'll use
what's referred to as a kind of
information bottleneck that tries to
essentially regularize a distribution
over theta to this gaussian
distribution um and so in particular
the
q of theta is representing we're
essentially adding noise to theta
according to the standard deviation
theta sub sigma
and then we're going to encourage that
distribution to look a lot like a
gaussian distribution which um
which doesn't which is some prior
distribution p of theta
um and this should ideally place
precedence on using information from the
training data over
using storing information and theta
was there a question
okay
in general this sort of
information bottleneck type approach is
um
maybe not something that you've seen
before uh
well actually
the the tutorial tomorrow will actually
cover things that are related to this
particular kind of approach
but you can essentially think of it as a
regular regularization term that
encourages that adds noise to the
weights and encourages
um that distribution to
look gaussian
yeah
yeah so q um q is a gaussian
distribution um with mean
of theta sub mu and variance
uh theta sub sigma
um and so now we're actually storing two
parameter vectors one for the mean and
one for the variance and then when we
actually use the parameters what we're
going to do is we will take the mean and
add noise
basically sample from this distribution
in practice theta sigma is going to be a
diagonal covariance matrix so we can
just represent the diagonal entries as a
vector
and it'll essentially correspond to
adding noise proportional to theta sub
sigma
yeah
yeah so p theta um this is just a prior
uh it's common to use a gaussian prior
here
um
and because you can measure the kl
divergence between gaussians in closed
form which is pretty nice um and then
you can use what's called the
re-parametrization trick to actually
differentiate through the sampling
process from a gaussian
and this
reprimatization trick will be covered um
on thursday for people who aren't
familiar with it
yeah um
yeah awesome so the way that we use q is
um
we sample from it um and
the each sample from it will be a
parameter vector
and we'll use that parameter vector to
um
parametrize the metal error
yeah um and the
so
in this case theta is referring to the
meta parameters and we're essentially
trying to regularize the meta parameters
and so when we sample from this the
result of that sample will actually be
the meta parameters um rather than
task-specific parameters and you can
apply this objective
um both to
blackbox approaches as well as to like
optimization-based approaches yeah um
yeah so this is essentially like adding
noise to the weights you can also do
something like dropout on weights i
haven't actually seen people do that
before
people normally do drop out on
activations um
but i would also imagine that that would
reduce information and data
right so it will definitely look similar
to doing it on activations it will be a
little bit different because like it's a
matrix rather than a vector and so the
the outcome of the matrix vector
multiplication will be different
um
one thing that we did actually try was
applying this regularizer to the
activations rather than the weights and
we did actually find that it worked
better on the weights because that's
where it's storing the canonical
information
or like the canonical pose for example
cool um if you don't quite understand
this equation you can essentially think
of it as adding noise to theta by
essentially with the goal of trying to
minimize the information in theta and
encourage the model to use
use information from the training set
for the support set
okay um and then yeah you can combine
this with both black box approaches and
optimization based approaches
yeah
so here i guess you're just trying to
keep the rates of the applications
um it's actually trying to keep it close
to a zero mean
standard gaussian um if you initialize
with the zero mean standard gaussian
then yes um although you might
initialize somewhere else
why is that stopping from
memorizing that
i guess one thing that is a little bit
different than just trying to keep it
close to the initialization is we are
actually adding noise now we're not just
saying that you should stay close to the
initialization we're saying that you
should um
your weight should look similar to this
particular distribution when you add
noise and the noisy weights are the ones
that you have to use not the not the
mean
yeah so um
you can also do l2 on meta parameters
and actually l2 is uh
actually quite similar to this kl um
it's essentially assuming that you
fix the variance to one
and you don't learn the variance of this
distribution
um it is pretty important to add the
noise though um to the weights and you
can essentially think of it as lt
regularization on the weights plus
adding noise
okay
cool so as an example for how well this
works if you take omniglot and you don't
shuffle the labels such that
um the mapping that kind of corresponds
between image classes and labels
is consistent across all of the tasks
um so it's non-mutually exclusive then
for mammal we see the performance like i
mentioned before
um there's another approach called task
agnostic metal learning that tries to
regularize
in a way that encourages the model to
predict different things although it
ends up being something that the model
can kind of cheat around
um whereas this kind of meta
regularization on the weights that's
what the mrnw stand for
does a lot better at allowing the model
to actually adapt from the data allowing
it to ultimately generalize to new image
classes
and if you take the post-prediction task
that i mentioned before um
uh you also see a pretty significant
improvement in the mean squared error on
but when you use the meta regularization
compared to
um not using metal equalization
cmp is conditional neural processes it
corresponds to a black box approach and
you also see an improvement for the
black box approaches as well
will be replaced by
90 meter
situation behind this new object here is
true
but i want to maximize the remedies of
my friendship as much as possible
i wanted to
yeah so the question is can you replace
this kl term with an entropy term that
encourages the weights to be more more
and more random essentially
um
i think that uh in principle you should
be able to do something like that i
don't think that we explicitly tried it
um one challenge that can come up is
that i think that like maximizing
entropy can be
um
can be somewhat difficult
i guess um
one thing that might one issue that
might come up is it might
maximize the entropy of some dimensions
of the weights that aren't important
and not others that are that it's
actually using in practice and that
might um cause it to maximize entropy in
a way that doesn't actually
um prevent memorization
uh but i'd have to that's kind of my uh
kind of
initial reaction i'd have to think about
it more
yeah
yeah so this is actually already pretty
close to maximum entropy because um
gaussian distributions are like the for
a fixed variance it's the kind of
maximal
entropy distribution that you can get um
so it is already doing something pretty
similar to maximum entropy
yeah so great question so why not um how
does this compare to just like shuffling
in a way that kind of makes the tasks
mutually exclusive
in general i didn't
i don't have them in this slide but you
can actually get better performance by
shuffling the labels in cases where
that's possible to do
in the pose prediction task it's a
little bit harder to um
it's a little bit harder to shuffle you
can't just shuffle the labels you
actually need to
like shuffle the canonical orientations
of different objects essentially
um and then in other cases uh you just
can't like shuffle the labels like in
the robotics example that i mentioned
before
um in general shuffling labels is more
reliable than this regularizer
in settings where you can do it
okay and then one other thing i'll
mention is we um if you compare this
kind of regularization on the weights to
things like weight decay um like like
like was asked and um and what's called
uh base by backdrop um
the you do actually see a um
a pretty significant difference it's not
just uh as simple as just running
standard regularization on the model um
and this weight decay example here is
one where we didn't add noise we just
did
adjusted
weight decay on the weights um and so
this is illustrating why the noise is
really important
yeah
um
[Music]
yeah so that would um if you if you add
a random
angle
like to this task and you like do that
multiple times to kind of create
additional copies of the task then you
are essentially creating making it such
that the tasks are
um
are now mutually exclusive and you i
wouldn't have the memorization problem
again and i think that you i would guess
that you would probably do a bit better
than using um
than using this kind of regularization
approach because you're actually in that
case actually forcing it to use the data
cool and then one other quick note that
i'll mention um
is you can actually look at uh try to
like theoretically derive the
generalization benefits of
this kind of regularizer
and
if you let kind of p of theta be an
arbitrary distribution like a gaussian
distribution
then you can actually derive a
generalization bound um for
uh
for the model this looks pretty
complicated but essentially what it is
is measuring the generalization error is
trying to
upper bound that generalization error
which corresponds to error on the meta
training set and then also um this meta
regularization term
and if you essentially do like a taylor
expansion of the right-hand side
and choose a particular value of
beta on the regularization weight then
you'll actually
recover the objective exactly
um i don't want to go into too much of
the details here but for people who are
kind of interested in some of the
theoretical side of things
um you might find this interesting and
you could look at the paper
cool and then the proof for this
relies heavily on this this other work
that looks at um kind of theoretic
theoretical aspects of multitask
learning
cool um
so to summarize the memory the the
memorization problem
it's kind of an instance of meta
overfitting
where you are essentially memorizing the
functions underlying the training tasks
and this is somewhat analogous to
standard overfitting in supervised
learning where you're memorizing your
training data points so you're kind of
instead of memorizing your data points
you're memorizing your tasks
we see that one solution to this is to
try to control the information flow
this is different from
kind of standard regularization in
supervised learning where you're trying
to regularize the hypothesis class
um but the solution for controlling the
information flow that we actually used
is to actually regularize the
description length of the meta
parameters um
which uh actually does look pretty
similar to regularizing your hypothesis
class
um
although it is actually somewhat
interesting that the kind of
regularization that we use this gaussian
prior on the weights
[Music]
isn't
doesn't always actually work that well
for deep neural networks
and so it's kind of interesting that you
see that these pretty drastic
improvements in some of the metal
learning scenarios
but i wouldn't expect to see those kinds
of improvements in the standard
supervised scenarios
okay cool um
any remaining questions
cool so
now that we've talked about uh
constructing tasks in a way that is
ideally mutually exclusive or requiring
this sort of memorization um i like to
talk about a scenario where maybe you
don't have
a lot of meta training tasks or maybe
you don't have any meditating tasks and
you only have unlabeled data
and so in particular
one of the things you might have noticed
is that uh fu shot learning is awesome
but you do actually require tasks to be
constructed from labeled data or from
demonstrations of many previous tasks or
label data from other regions and so
you're still
still require a lot of labels ultimately
and what if we only have unlabeled data
um it'd be nice to be able to do few
shop metal learning from unlabeled
images or unlabeled text and so forth
um
is
yeah this is a great question there is
essentially two aspects of defining
tasks one is grouping the data
into these tasks which could correspond
to
like geographical metadata
uh another is like once you have those
groupings actually labeling those
groupings and and having like a labeled
support set in the labeled query set
um both of those are
are important aspects of it um
in the next couple slides i'll talk
about how we could actually like have
approaches that handle the case where
you don't know either of them you just
have unlabeled image data or unlabeled
text data
um
but there aren't like these same sort of
techniques could be used if you have the
groupings but don't have the labels
within those groupings
cool um so a general recipe that we
could do uh for this sort of thing is we
have an unlabeled data set we want to
propose tasks in some way from this
unlabeled data and then run meta
learning on those
tasks now of course the big question is
how do we propose tasks from unlabeled
data
and essentially the goal of these
methods is to try to automatically
construct tasks from unlabeled data in a
way that tries to prepare us for solving
some test tasks that we want the model
to be able to solve
um so does anyone have thoughts on like
what you might want these constructed
tasks to look like
this is fairly open-ended
um
yeah so if you don't know the groupings
you could try to use clustering to kind
of group the data in some way we
actually i guess we sort of saw that in
the uh the land cover classification
example
other thoughts
is there a way that you can determine
like maybe maybe you have a method for
proposing tasks how would you understand
if that's like a good method or not
yeah cool so you could
sample a bunch of tasks and see if if
you run metal learning on those tasks
can it
then learn new tasks from that same
sampling scheme and what would that tell
you if it can't
how are you doing
the data yeah yeah so if basically if it
doesn't generalize to the task that you
sample then that means that uh you're
creating tasks in a way that doesn't
kind of for which the support set
doesn't tell you much about how to solve
the query set
cool so
um
essentially the kind of two things that
i had in mind is first we want the
sample task to be diverse
because
ultimately if you have some test tasks
that you want to be able to solve with a
small amount of labels
then if you have a diverse set of tasks
then it should it's more likely to cover
those tasks
and then the second thing that you want
is you want them to be structured and in
particular
um
if they don't have any shared structure
to them then you may not actually be
able to kind of get any information from
the support set and then it wouldn't be
able to perform futile learning we'd see
the same issue that was brought up
cool so we ultimately need we want both
of these because if we have completely
random tasks they're super diverse but
they're not structured enough
and likewise the opposite would be bad
as well
um
so next we'll look at a method for
constructing tasks from unlabeled image
data and also
task construction from unlabeled text
data
cool um so
the the first approach that we'll look
at is actually heavily based on
clustering which is suggested so we'll
get some unsupervised
embedding space
and this will essentially allow us to
map from images into some lower
dimensional embedding space
then we can
cluster the images within this embedding
space
to get different um
to get different tasks that correspond
to discriminating different clusters and
so for example
um we can sample some tests or cluster
these images into
uh in the embedding space to get
different clusters and then different
tasks will correspond to
discriminating these different clusters
and so for example what we could do is
we want to sample a new task we'll
sample two clusters
these two clusters will correspond to
two classes or different classes within
that classification task the number of
classes the number of clusters you
sample will correspond to the number of
classes
and then we can sample new images within
those clusters to get a query
set um
and then we can do this likewise for
like the purple cluster and the green
cluster to get another task um and this
would give us
um a two-way one-shot classification
task
images
yeah so this is going to be specific to
classification tasks um it won't
necessarily be specific to certain data
sets but
it will be a way to get different
classification tasks
i haven't thought too much about how you
would get regression tasks
at least in in this circumstance
so i'm not sure exactly how you would
get regression tasks
yeah
um
yeah so the question is how do you
determine like the number of clusters uh
and
generally if you um
if you know anything about your meta
test task like maybe you know that you
have like a few examples of a binary
classification test then what you could
do is you could make a bunch of binary
classification tasks um if you don't
know exactly what it's going to be then
what you can do is just set it to be
sufficiently large such that um you're
training it on classification tests are
like up to like 50 way for example and
then
um then your your metal earner should be
able to generalize to tasks that are um
uh that are up to 50 way for example
um
yeah so i think that
i guess the question is is this kind of
shifting the responsibility from the
um
from
the kind of metal learning process to
the task construction process
and it certainly is shifting
responsibility
and the design of these tasks like you
do want it to kind of reflect the kinds
of tasks like ultimately you want to
reflect the kinds of tasks that you'll
see at meta test time and you want there
to be kind of as close of overlap as you
can get
um and so
in many ways these kinds of approaches
may end up being somewhat domain
specific um
and in the sense that you want to um
construct tasks in an unsupervised way
that do cover the tasks in that domain
that you care about
does that answer your question
yeah
yeah so the question is like doesn't
this depend on how good your initial
embedding space is and it certainly does
um
the
what we're actually going to use in this
case is um there's an approach called
deep cluster that actually kind of
integrates representation learning and
clustering so that you're actually using
the clustering to get the representation
but if you have a better representation
learning method then you could also
use that
and really the natural baseline here
will be to compare the result of metal
learning on these tasks
to doing some sort of thing like linear
classifier on top of that embedding
space
and your goal is to be able to do better
than just like a linear classifier on
that embedding space
cool so um here's one example of how you
can construct tasks with this sort of
clustering approach
um and we want to get essentially a
representation that's particularly
suitable for few shot learning of
downstream tasks compared to this
original representation space
um
in terms of some of the details um you
can use it like i guess this paper was
from a couple years ago and so these are
a little bit outdated at this point but
you can use representation learning
methods like this by can or
or something like deep cluster which
does integrate clustering and
representation learning
um
your
method is referred to as clustering to
automatically construct tasks for
unsupervised meta-learning or cactus
it's a bit of a
forest acronym um and then we used a
mammal and prioritizable networks
and if you're curious what a
uh
a forced acronym with a mammal looks
like or a cactus mammal you get
something like this
and uh if you look at performance on
mini imagenet uh five-way five-shot
classification um
first like kind of our
oracle method is to use mammal with all
of the labels on the
data
then we could take the representation
from bygand and do k-nearest neighbors
on that representation we get around a
31 success rate on these five shot tasks
we could also do logistic regression on
top of that representation we do a
little bit better um
if you want you could all we tried
regularizing it and doing mlp that
actually did worse than just logistic
regression
we also tried some sort of cluster
matching
um
and then when we actually ran the um red
middle learning on top of the tasks that
were derived from this representation we
see a performance of 51 which is kind of
substantially better than 33
because you're essentially preparing the
uh the representation for the ability to
do fuchsia learning
um and then also if you use the deep
cluster representation this actually
this kind of shows you the kind of
dependence of this method on the
representation it does actually do
better with a deep cluster
representation than the bygan
representation
so these are the results for kind of one
few shot classification tasks
i won't show all the others but it's
really the same kind of trend and story
for
different embedding methods for
different data sets um
and these different data sets also
includes things like attribute uh
prediction and syllabi
um
pro typical networks underperforms in
some cases but we generally saw the same
story with both mammal and pro-typical
networks
and then we also see that this works
well if you have larger data sets um i
think that
we looked at like data sets of up to 100
shot or something like that
foreign
yeah so um
there is kind of some domain knowledge
that's kind of like
kind of inherently a part of the method
based on the number of like clusters
that you choose and ultimately like
what representation you use and so forth
um and
actually
what i was going to talk about next is
can we actually even use even more
domain knowledge when constructing these
tasks and uh
for example like there are scenarios in
image classification where we know that
there are certain data augmentations
that will still preserve the label and
we can use this domain knowledge to
actually construct even better tasks
so
for example we know that things like
dropping out some pixels or translating
the image or reflecting the image those
sorts of things generally don't change
the image class and if you know that
you're going to be doing image
classification problems you could try to
integrate this domain knowledge into the
tasks
um and so you can get transformations
that look something like this or
something like this
and then when you do test construction
um instead of doing the clustering
approach that i mentioned before you can
randomly sample n images and assign them
labels one through n
so for example you could sample these
three images assign assign them labels
one two three
this will be
your support set and then for each data
point
in this support set you can augment the
example using your domain knowledge to
construct other examples of the same
image class
and this can be your query set
so
this is stored in d train this is stored
in d test and this is essentially
another way to construct tasks except
with completely unlabeled data
except now we're going to be using
domain knowledge to potentially
construct better tasks because we can
essentially get lots of data of um
of
like support query sets with these
different transformations
cool um how do you actually go about
augmenting in practice for omniglot they
use translation and random pixel drop
out and for many imagenet they used
what's referred to as auto augment which
does a combination of translation
rotation and shearing
and
the result is that
this sort of approach
did
really
super well on omniglot
it's able to
do
it's able to bridge a lot of the gap
between
unsupervised methods and fully
supervised methods and in for example
the five-way five-shot case it's getting
a 95
uh accuracy despite only having five
examples per class
um this is where we have like pretty
good domain knowledge because the images
are relatively simple
uh
and then on many images that we see that
it kind of slightly
underperforms the the clustering-based
approach probably just because
clustering is a pretty good
uh
pretty good domain knowledge in terms of
trying to do some sort of image
classification
okay
so that's the image case what about if
we have unlabeled text
one option is to just formulate it as a
language modeling problem we've seen
this with things like gpg3 t5 and so
forth
where essentially d train is kind of a
sequence of characters d-test is the
following sequence of characters and you
can construct tasks by trying to predict
what will come next and formulating the
training data as
text
and so
we saw this where you could kind of
construct tasks like math problems as
text and
spelling correction problems as text and
so forth
um
we might not use this option in all
cases so
um this approach is harder to combine
with these optimization based approaches
because
um
you don't have like a
clear like
input and labels for example
um it's also hard to apply this to
classification tasks um you could
i mean you could formulate a
classification task as a prediction test
where you need to predict a token of
like zero or one for example
but if you actually tell the model that
if the output is only gonna be zero or
one and it has to pick between them um
then kind of formulating it as a
classification problem is easier than
formulating it as a language generation
problem
and so another option that has been
explored is to try to construct tasks by
masking out words
um and then the task is to classify the
masked word
and so what this looks like is you
sample a subset of unique words
assign them
an id
so for example you might pick the words
democratic and capital and
assign them the id of one and two
then sample a bunch of sentences with
those words
and mask the word out
and then construct a support set in a
query set with the mask sentences and
then the corresponding word ids are the
labels
and so as an example of what a training
data set would look like is you would
give it a sentence like this this has a
class label of one because
the mask word here is democratic
this would also have a math label of one
this one would have a label of two and
this one would have a label of two and
so this is your support set with kind of
inputs x and labels y
um and then in terms of your test set
then you get a new query within
kind of also with a masked out word and
then you need to predict
one or two
so you can do this with um
with this completely unlabeled text and
get a bunch of classification problems
out
any questions on how this works
yeah
um so how much support data or how much
mediterranean data
um
so good question so the question is how
much mediterranean data do you need to
do this well
um
i guess it probably depends on how
complex your test your your text is so
if you have very broad
text um
like uh the
like you need to understand the kind of
context and so forth as well um it's
also going to depend on what you choose
for like anyway and k shot as well so if
you see
um a lot of examples per class
that makes it easier if you have a lot
of classes then you actually need to
understand language a lot more to
understand what should go in that blank
um rather than like you might be able to
do some simple pattern matching if you
have just two classes
so it's probably going to depend a lot
on the the details of the data set
cool so um
here are a bunch of numbers
the
results on the left are methods that do
this entirely unsupervised pre-training
approach whereas the methods on the
right are doing some sort of supervised
or semi-supervised pre-training
and so
in particular the approach that we
mentioned before is in the second column
and this is in comparison to bert
and then everything on the right is
actually combining the generated tasks
with supervised tasks you're sort of
doing like semi-supervised med learning
where you have some supervised tasks and
some unsupervised tasks
and then there's likewise other kind of
semi-supervised approaches that are also
being compared to
and in particular burt is a standard
self-supervised learning method
the second column is the kind of
proposed unsupervised metal learning
approach
mtbert is doing multi-test learning and
fine-tuning on supervised tasks
uh
leopard is an optimization based metal
learner
um that's only doing it on the
supervised tasks again
and then this hybrid method is doing
metal learning on the proposed tasks as
well as on the supervised tasks
and so the comparison between leopard
and smlmt
is um is showing you how much those
unsupervised tasks are helping in
comparison to only using the supervised
tasks
cool and then in terms of the results um
we see that the
i mean first in terms of the last two
columns we see that there is a pretty
substantial or significant improvement
between using the unsupervised tasks in
addition to only using the supervised
tasks um and then we also see
improvements over um
bert with fine tuning yeah
yeah i'm not sure exactly why that's the
case um
they might they probably have more more
details on the paper about it um i can't
remember exactly what that
um what that data set corresponds to
um it could be that maybe when they set
the ratio of the supervised tasks and
unsupervised tasks maybe they
set the ratio of supervised tasks too
high and maybe they're overfitting to
those supervised tasks
um but yeah i'd have to take a look at
the paper for for more and there is more
results and analysis in the paper as
well
cool um
so
that's an overview of unsupervised med
learning and how we can try to construct
tasks from unlabeled image data and
unlabeled
unlabeled text data as well and we can
also combine those on label tasks with
supervised tasks as well as a form of
task augmentation
we have a bit more time so i'll also
briefly talk about one other
unsupervised med learning scenario
which is um what do we have time series
and the time series is actually
labeled
so for example maybe we want to predict
energy demand or we want to predict the
dynamics of a robot or a car or
transportation usage or
we want to make some money and we want
to predict the stock market
video analytics
or reinforcement learning agent
oftentimes we do actually have lots of
streams of data but they're fully
unsegmented in the sense that they
aren't like really broken into tasks
and so we actually have this is actually
a scenario where we have the label data
but we don't have the groupings into
tasks
and so we want to be able to somehow get
the groupings of tasks and do med
learning in a way that allows us to very
quickly
predict for a new time series um with a
small amount of data
um
cool so it's unsegmented we do have
temporal structure like in many cases
there are kind of
discrete points in time where something
changes
um like maybe maybe like facebook stock
may have had a discrete change earlier
this week
so
um can we segment the the time series
into tasks and then metal learn across
those tasks
another question becomes how to segment
um
there's a class of approaches called uh
change point detection methods that try
to essentially detect where those
discrete changes happen
um
and in particular
uh you kind of assume that the tasks
will switch with some probability at
every single time step
um and so
you could kind of view it according to
this visual where each of the dashed
lines are
essentially like a change point in the
task and the function is essentially
kind of like piecewise linear
and then
once we
make this assumption then we should
maintain a belief over the task duration
or the run length
and
estimate some distribution over what we
think
the duration is
and so in particular for this example we
would
kind of the run length or the task
duration for each of these tasks is
increasing by one at each time step
until you hit that change point and then
it goes back to zero and increases again
um so
uh in this uh in this work they showed
that you can actually
uh update the belief recursively based
off of models the the model performance
and essentially figure out uh
simply update your belief over where the
what the task duration is and figure out
whether or not there is a change point
at the current time step or not
now one of the cool things about this
approach is that this
because it's actually representing these
probabilities over your
um
over the run length uh this procedure is
actually fully differentiable
um and so what you can do is you can
actually back propagate uh
through the update uh the belief update
um
into a model that's being meta-trained
to perform few shot classification on
this time series
um and so uh kind of the result is you
can do uh in some metatrading phase
you're given some unsegmented time
series
uh of of offline data
and then at test time you're given kind
of streaming online
data
and what you'll do is you will
essentially do metal learning and do a
kind of joint change point prediction
and if you shot metal learning over
these segments in your time series
and then at meta test time you'll use
your few shot learner to predict forward
and also
use what you learned before to also
predict where the change points are
and so you can do something like
sinusoid regression where you have
discrete shifts in the actual sinusoid
function
and you get a cool visualization like
this where the um the red is predicting
the ground truth sinusoid function at
the given point in time
and then the blue is showing the model's
predictions
for that sinusoid
and you can see that very quickly when
it gets a new
um when it gets a new sinusoid it
realizes that it realizes that the task
has changed and then it's able to very
quickly identify what the
correct curve is
and then at the same time the algorithm
is also maintaining its kind of current
belief over the run length and whether
or not the the task has actually changed
cool um and you can also make a
streaming version of mini imagenet um
and also get um kind of allow it to
identify when the task has changed so
the blue curve is showing kind of the
test accuracy in the streaming setting
whereas the gray top curve is showing
some oracle so you do get a performance
hit because the task is actually
changing at test time
um
but you are you are actually able to do
still fairly well in the setting um and
then the the window-based approaches are
just treating different tasks of
different windows in time
cool yeah so the x-axis is the rate at
which the change points are coming um
and so
further to the right means that you have
change points more frequently um and
it gets harder understandably and then
to the left means that the change points
are happening less frequently so the
task is changing less frequently
yes average over over all time
yeah
cool um so
[Music]
that's it for today to recap we talked
about task construction um we talked
about
how memorization issues can come up if
you if you construct your tasks in or if
you're in scenarios where your tasks are
not um are not mutually exclusive and we
talked about one solution that seems to
work well for classification tasks at
least but it's i don't think it's
necessarily the final solution
we also talked about how we can
potentially try to construct tasks in an
unsupervised fashion either from
unlabeled text data and unlabeled image
data or from time series that isn't
segmented
um
cool and then next time
on monday next week we're going to have
our last metal learning like supervised
metal learning lecture where we'll talk
about bayesian metal learning and how
you can cast metal learning into the
framework of bayesian graphical models
um
if you're not familiar with
tools from variational inference i'd
encourage you to go to the tutorial at
4pm tomorrow
yeah and then i'll see everyone next
week